Good evening. Thank you all for being with us today. My name is
Kat. My pronouns are she and her. And we're so happy that you've
chosen to be with us, whether this is your first time here or
your first time in a long time. We're so happy that you're here.
Our kids ministry is hosting a fall fest for families to have
fun and connect on Friday, October 17th. If you have kids
through the sixth grade, please save the date for this fun night
at the Runford home here in Sachse. There will be game snacks
as well as pumpkin carving contest or pumpkin painting for the
littles. Scan the QR code to RSVP. We'd love to have you. The
sixth anniversary of the table is coming up in November, and to
do that, we are doing an annual chili cook off after service on
November 2nd. If you would like to show off your favorite chili
recipe, you can scan the QR code and sign up. And our next service
day for five Lowe's food pantry will be Saturday, December 6th
at 915 a.m. to 12. If you would like information and volunteer to
work in the five Lowe's food pantry, please scan the QR code and
sign up. We'd appreciate that. These candles are a sign of the
presence of Christ among us, fully divine but fully human. Now I
will call you into worship. We're going to exit the kingdom of
noise, hurry and productivity, and now we enter into the kingdom of
silence, stillness and grace. Now we enter sacred space, a space for
prayer, worship, and adoration, a space to encounter Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of creation. Allow the unforced
rhythms of grace to find you, to mend your heart. May we all come
home. Thank you, Kat. I see a couple of faces that I don't recognize,
so just real quickly I wanted to introduce ourselves. I'm Mindy. This
is my twin sister Maggie, in case you feel like you're seeing double.
And this is Gary. And we're here not to, you know, put on a
performance for you, but hoping that we can help create a space all
around us that we believe kind of anchor us in to who God is and the
love that he has for us. So if you guys want to stand with us and
worship, if you're able, or you can sit back and take it in, whatever
you're comfortable with, we just want you to know that you're welcome in
this space, and we just encourage you to utilize it however you need to
for the love that God has for us and who loves us.
Thank you.
And I thank you.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud and for those that we've kept in our hearts, we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing and hope, peace and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
just too exhausted for anyone to win you know uh that's i just think that's that's bad i think it's
bad christian theology i'm like this makes no sense the way sergius volgogov put it is this he
said those who proclaim the infinity of torments also necessarily affirm the eternity of evil and
its co-eternity with good right and this he just rejects he's just like no no no no love wins evil
is not and cannot in christian theology be co-equal to the god who is love now you may be wondering
though what about hell and judgment in the language in scripture you know about eternal damnation
you know the there's the sheep and the goats you know the uh the wheat and the tares all of that
like i mentioned i'll get more into that next week um for now suffice it to say that i think
most people interpret those passages as the end of the story right hey this is just how it ends
it's like super sad but it's just how it goes you know some people are sheep and some people are
goats if it makes no sense to you go read matthew 25 and then it'll be it's a metaphor for human
beings right um some people are the good wheat matthew 13 and some are the evil tares you know
the weeds and such and that's just you know that's that's how it goes uh and this i'd say well yeah
i mean certainly the language of like hell and judgment uh gehenna and such that's in the bible
i mean even on the lips of jesus himself and i'm not shying away from that uh gregory of nyssa
maximus the confessor others saint isaac the syrian uh they didn't shy away from it and i think
though again bulgakov puts it quite nicely he says you know many christians when they hear those
passages they think to themselves ah yes that that's it that's christian eschatology that's
the end of the story and bulgakov puts it so beautifully he just says no no no that's not
the end that's the beginning that's the beginning of eschatology it's the end of this age this ion
as we'll get into next week it's the end of this era this time but it's the beginning of a new one
and uh and ultimately that's that beginning of that new thing that's the movement towards
something beautiful towards something healing and you say but how do we know you know well
because of all the passages that speak of this apocatastasis this restoration of all scriptures
like acts 3 19 through 21 repent then and turn to god so that your sins may be wiped out that times
of refreshing may come from the lord that he may send the messiah who has been appointed for you
even jesus heaven must receive him until he until the time comes for god to restore apocatastasis
restore everything as he promised long ago through his holy prophets
romans 11 32 for god has bound everyone over to disobedience by the way that's that's talking
about the cross right in the cross we see just the worst of humanity i mean can you imagine like
just a more heinous awful thing that human minds devise like it's just a picture of just like
evil you know and the disturbing thing about christian theology is it says it's not like
well those bad people they put jesus on the cross you know it's kind of disturbing and it says
we like humanity collectively like we did that like this is what we're capable of that that evil
like it's in me it's disturbing you know it's a disturbing idea so god's bound everyone over
to disobedience but then what does it say so that he may have mercy on them all
i mean that's a that's a profound verse it's a it's amazing me that how we read these verses
and i think because we have a certain understanding of hell we just i don't know it just like goes
over you know it's like well it means the christians you know i don't that's just not
what it said you know i mean so i don't know maybe i'm like a little fundamentalist here
i've never really been known that way but i'm like this is the bible you know so i don't even
argue with scripture you know um first corinthians 15 22 boy i've been told that a lot um for as an
atom all die so also in christ shall what all be made alive it's amazing how we'll kind of all
agree like oh yes you know an atom or at least certain christians like oh everyone yeah everyone
sins and ever we all put jesus on the cross but no not all will be made alive and you know i mean
like no that's just for the good people you know that's not what it says first john 2 2 he is the
propitiation the atonement the appeasement the healing for our sins and not for ours only but
also for the sins of the christians you know no of the whole world the whole world i mean it's
such good news see i'm telling you guys turn that world upside down like there's some hope you know
i mean romans 5 18 and 19 consequently just as one trespass resulted in condemnation for all people
so also one righteous act resulted in justification in life for all people for just as through the
disobedience of the one man the many were made sinners so also through the obedience of the one
man the many will be made righteous then my personal favorite cautions 119 through 20
for in him all the fullness of god was pleased to dwell and through him as christ to reconcile
to himself all things whether on earth or in heaven making peace by the blood of his cross
yeah that's that's it all right that's the great christian eschatological hope and i really i think
it's like better news than most christians seem to realize so i don't want to shy away from it
you know i mean i want to preach it and talk about it and we'll spend the next few weeks kind of
delving into it so i'll go ahead and close with this i preached at a different church a few months
ago and uh it was a sunday morning where like we had like two services but sunday school in the
middle you know so i thought like i'm just gonna just kind of jump in a little i'll just see what
what the folks are up to in this you know kind of random local church or whatever and uh so i walk
in and i did kind of stand out everyone was like 75 years old not old enough you know even though
they're young people to try i guess they didn't go to sunday school i don't know so just me and
you know some older folks were sitting there and uh they were going through a kind of typical
protestant uh interpretation of the book of revelation and it was like a video series so
we watched like the final video and and it just happened to be like the last you know week in the
series and this very famous kind of evangelical mega church pastor i won't say who but he was
kind of bringing this to a stirring conclusion you know is he like describing the new jerusalem
coming down from heaven like revelation all that and uh how all the believers know enjoy
eternity with god the video closed and the leaders wanted to kind of open it up for discussion
you know and so they're like uh hey just anyone chime in like what are your thoughts what are
your you know what do you think about this whole series they spent like you know 10 weeks or
something going through this and it was so awkward we all just sat there in total silence i mean of
course i wasn't going to say anything it's like i'm new here you know uh and we're just sitting
there no one says anything and finally one of the leaders chimed in you know somebody's got to do
that to get the conversation going so she said you know oh man said i'm grateful i'm grateful to know
that even though everything is getting worse and the people of earth are in for a terrible time
i'm just glad that i'll be raptured away to heaven and i won't have to experience any of that
she said how about you all
and again everyone just sits there silent and finally one man speaks up with great agitation
in his voice he said i hate it that's what he said he said i hate that so all the people of
earth suffer while we all get whisked away to heaven everyone else suffers in hell forever
while we enjoy heaven is this christ is this what we've spent years learning
i hate it and you know in that moment like he lacked you know the kind of theological
sophistication to like this is about the apocatastasis and you gotta interpret you
know i mean like none of that's happening um but in the end you know i think he's right
i hate that too like there is a way of understanding christian theology and eschatology
that is kind of the worst it is it's like it's it's kind of evacuation theology um you know
we'll all fly away to heaven and leave the world to burn um but no no i don't think that's that's
quite the great christian hope hope is apocatastasis the hope is the restoration
and healing of all things that's the hope and uh boy do we need that kind of hope right now
in the name of the father the son the holy spirit amen
so on the night jesus was betrayed he had one final meal with his disciples and at that meal
he held up a loaf of bread he broke it and he said take it eat this is my body it's broken for you
then he held up a cup of wine he said take this drink this is my blood it's shed for you
whenever you eat this bread whenever you drink this cup remember me and so as we come to the
table tonight that's what we center on we center on christ our great hope the way we'll participate
in communion is we're just going to go kind of row by row starting here at the front and forming
a line right here in the middle uh if you um well for some folks you know kind of wonder like well
how do i like partake and such so basically no one will lead you through the exact moment
of taking you can just kind of do that whenever however you'd like um you should know the red
is wine and the white is grape juice and finally practice what's called an open table so if you're
here tonight and you'd like to participate regardless of your like exact denomination
or theology or whatever um you're welcome to uh to participate so this is the table
not of the church but of the lord and it's made ready for those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you who have much faith and you who have little you who have been
here often and you who have not been here long you who have tried to follow and you who feel
like you failed come come because it's the lord jesus himself who invites you and it's his will
that those who want to meet him should meet him here come to the table
so
many sunday nights we end with kind of a more reflective song where we could sit back and sort
of kind of take in the message and maybe have some introspection but tonight um knowing what
brett was going to be talking about i wanted to end on kind of a note of hope for us as we go out
so if you guys would stand with us again if you're able um we're gonna sing good god um believing
that he is um he is weaving something good into our lives he is up to something good in the world
and we have the opportunity to join him in that
be still my soul be still my soul be still and know that my god is here
be still my soul be still my soul be still and know that my god is here all that i need
to know is this you are a good guy the maker of heaven calls me his you are a good guy and your
heart beats in my chest
i won't be afraid i won't be afraid i won't be afraid my god is here
he will make a way he will make a way he will make a way my god is here all that i need to know is
this you are a good guy the maker of heaven calls me in you are a good guy and your heart beats in
my chest
you gave me your eyes you gave me your heart your spirit flows through my veins
you gave me your eyes you gave me your heart your spirit flows through my veins you give
me your eyes you give me your heart your spirit flows through my veins you give me your eyes
you give me your heart your spirit flows through my veins and you gave me your eyes you gave me
your heart you had a plan right from the start and i know who i am because i know who you are
you are good
all that i need to know is this
the maker of heaven calls me here
you are a good God
and your heart beats in my chest
all that i have to do is pray
you are a good God
thank you so much for being with us this evening
we would like for you to fill out a visitor's card at the table on your way out
or scan the QR code and fill out an online visitor's card
so that way if you have any questions we can answer them
and just say thank you for being here
generosity is a key aspect of adoration
and adoration in the life of worship
and if you call the table home and would like to give financially
you can also scan the QR code and find out information about that
and if you call the table home and are interested in serving on one of our ministry teams
we have several to choose from
you can scan the code and find one that works for you
we have AV and we have our praise team
we have our kids ministry
we have our host team
there's many things that you can jump in and do if you feel like serving
and also we have meetups which are very important in our community
and you can also scan the QR code
we should scan that right now and just have it up on his point
no I'm kidding
there's different meetups that meet at different times of the week
at different people's houses
and it's a great time to connect and reflect
vent or whatever you need to do
so look into the meetups
I'd like to send you out with this benediction
you can hold your hands out in a posture to receive
open your hearts to these words
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day
so as you go out into your week ahead
that's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and desire to extend these same gifts of grace and peace
and unconditional love to everyone that you come in contact with
be blessed
have a great week
and we hope to see you back here next Sunday
good night
you